[음악]
지금 어디 가고 계시는 거죠? 성수동
가고 있습니다. 유튜브 촬영하러 가고
있는데 저 이번에 저기 뭐야?
탑업 스토어 요번 주에 하거든요.
일단 우리 회사를 알리는 체험 공간
약간 요런 식으로 계획을 해야 되는데
어저께가 이제 월요일이었는데 좀
급으로 잡아 가지고
이게 혹시 그 예를 들어 800개 다
소진되면은 그다음 날 바로 또 만들
수 있나요? 그건 안 되죠. 네.
그럼 그럼 이제 3일에 800개
그러면 더 시켜 놔야 될 것
같은데요. 예. 그래서 저는 하루에
800개 정도 보시고 한
2,000개만 시켜 놓으시죠. 그
한에 얼마예요? 채나 굿주 같은 거는
사실 예 공수가 안 되다 보니까 아
좀 넉넉하게 하나 250원이라고요?
그러면 좀 넉넉하게 시키시죠?
그래요. 그럼 2,000개 해요?
저도 잘 모르겠습니다. 저도 귀신게
다 못 주면은 다시
[음악]
사고
중를
찾던 제가
고 준비가 되는게 가능한가요?
저도 사실
모르겠어요. 이게 지금 미션
인파사인데 일단 그 저희가 이제이
건물 중계했던 거 조금 내용 좀
담았고 그리고 이제 팝업 스토어 요번
주에 열리는 것도 간략하게 좀 설명을
했고 거기다 이제 저희가 드론샷까지
찍어 가지고 드론샷은 또 건물주분한테
선물로 드리려고요. 되게
좋아하시더라고요. 전에도 한번
촬영해서 드렸는데 어 너무 고맙다고
해 주셔 가지고 그리고 여기 인근에
또 드론샷 하나 또 찍을게 있거든요.
그래서 그것까지 찍고 회사로 넘어갈
거 같습니다.
[음악]
안에 안 들어가시나요?
생각보다 많아서 놀랐습니다. 되게
다양한 분들이 오셨고 외국인 분들도
되게 많으신 거 같아요. 사실
팝업스터 연하는게 사실 말도 안 되고
그렇면 국내 최초로 연 거 같은데 어
되게 이렇게 많은 사람들이 와 가지고
저도 되게 놀랬습니다.
[음악]
주변에 계신 분들도 되게
궁금해하더라고요. 예. 도대체 어떤
식으로 하길래 해가지고 아침부터
연락이 좀 많이 왔습니다. 물론 이제
첫 시도긴 하는데 되게 색다르고
재밌는 거 같아요. 그래서 앞으로도
좀 이런 기회가 있으면은 어 좀 자주
열면 좋을 것 같습니다. 그리고
회사를 홍보하는데 있어서도
외국인들한테도 홍보하기도 좋고 그리고
이제 외국 그 여행객들도 되게 많은데
어 한국 왔을 때 좀 이런 좋은
인상도 좀 심어주지 않을까네 그렇게
생각을 합니다. 되게 좀
재밌었습니다. 여기까지
[음악]